for these journalists working in uganda
is frustrating and sometimes dangerous
in march the independent online tv
station was raided by security officials
journalists were arrested for what the
government called cyber stalking and
offensive communication some say they
were tortured before being released on
bail anything in regards to broadcast
was taken
anything regarded to
office equipment from computers
to even mere
paperwork even
receipts may have received receipts for
fuel i mean everything was taken that's
why literally we closed because as you
move around you find in fact i i'm sure
you saw our team
as i do as it seems at our reception we
don't do anything
rights groups accuse president johary
museveni's government of silencing
critics museveni has been in power since
1986 the opposition said he has become
increasingly authoritarian cracking down
on voices of dissent and harassing
independent media outlets
that he causes the attacks on
journalists is
i think sheer
failure to appreciate the critical role
that the media plays in a democracy
where
the security and governments tend to
think that
once a journalist or media house carries
a story that is not in their favor they
are fighting them and against them they
do not appreciate the critical
importance of holding leaders to account
of exposing mass gross misuse of office
and power uganda's government says it is
not trying to muzzle the press but
journalists can't be allowed to publish
false news commit libel and fuel
incitement they are not going to come to
ignore a media house or journalists just
because they are
so you are talking about incidences of
crime and the security forces going in
there but it's not targeting the the
journalists
but some journalists in uganda feel the
state is targeting them and they say
more needs to be done to respect
people's rights to freedom of speech and
expression
hara mutasa al jazeera